welcome everyone to
voices with raviki i'm joined with my uh
i'm joined by and with my good friend uh
uh jonathan pajot
uh whose uh work on the symbolic world
um deeply resonates with a lot of what
i've been
doing work on and um and as many of you
don't know and i find jonathan
brilliantly insightful
and his reflections on the symbolic
aspects of existence and his ability
uh to uh uh re-shine and refurbish
uh these stories so that they can shine
for us again uh is
is often um you know it sort of catches
you um it's
deeply impressive uh so uh thank you
jonathan for coming
oh it's my pleasure i always enjoy
talking with you you know
ever since i discovered your work and
kind of
discovered the language which you're
developing also to talk about these
subjects it's been really helpful to me
i find myself thinking in the categories
that you are
that you are bringing forth and uh
especially speaking to uh
kind of a secular audience or also
convincing christians
that the the words they use have meaning
you know because sometimes
we have this kind of internal language
and and it stops to actually be
meaningful in the world and it just
becomes like a
kind of magical language so i've been
using your expressions uh
on attention the idea of relevant
realization all of these expressions
have been good to
to help people resee things in a
different frame so that they understand
them so i really
i i really appreciate our discussions
for sure
well thank you for saying that jonathan
i aspire
to this being true um that above and
beyond
trying to you know convince or persuade
people about
my specific claims truth claims
theoretical claims proposals
practical endeavors etc i aspire that i
do afford uh you know a vocabulary and a
grammar for people
uh that helps them uh to clarify and
develop
um their thinking i mean that's the art
that for me that's
that's the way in which i try to enact
the socratic ideal of being the midwife
right the midwife for other people um so
thank you for saying that that means a
lot to me
so uh what i wanted to start off
specifically talking about you released
two
excellent videos and i'll put the links
to them in the description of this video
uh one was on i i won't get the actual
verbatim
name one what was it was on sort of the
religious nature of a lot of the
demonstrations that are happening
uh around that were sort of galvanized
into existence by
uh the death of george floyd and then
you and then you did a follow-up they
were sort of like part one and part two
yeah on one on the the iconoclasm the
destruction of images the pulling down
of statues
and one of the things you did um
was you put your finger on a huge
important aspect of this
that is being completely ignored um
in the mainstream media but i think is
of vital importance
um as has happened in the past between
uh
you and i i are like very convergent i
was coming to very similar concerns
um and reflections um and i'd said some
things early on about how kobit was
going to accelerate the meeting crisis
and cause just a mental health tsunami
and you'd see
you know a proliferation of conspiracy
theory thinking um
you know you'd see purity code behavior
um
human beings are going to respond and
you know fashion to this invisible
ubiquitous threat that's uh causing them
to isolate and as you i like your uh
your invocation of the symbolic idea of
fasting
for most of their connections and so
and then i saw all of that um
and then when the protests began
um i had i so i wanna
i had a a reaction that made me sort of
recuse myself from commit
commenting on that publicly part of it
was a concern
that what she said in your first video
of just you know saying something that
would be premature polarizing
uh it was difficult to say anything that
was going to be
heard with it had any kind of nuance or
reflection to it
so part of it was just that kind of
caution
but it was a deeper issue for me i was
very concerned and i
i talked to my close friend about this
that i i would fall into a kind
of self-deceptive bias when i tried to
talk about any of this
so give me a moment please i i i don't
mean to trespass on your patients but
i want to in order to try and articulate
this and this has helped me upon
reflection i want to invoke
weber's distinction between the manifest
and the latent function
so to give you a classic example um
you know weber talked about uh the
manuscript
the manifest function of the bureaucracy
is to facilitate
you know information traveling upward
and decisions start going downward
and that's its manifest function but it
has all kinds of latent functions it has
the latent function
of allowing people to diffuse
responsibility and shift blame onto
others
and kafka of course brought this into
high art he showed us how the latent
function
can you know uh put us into a tragic
situation because
our commitment to the manuscripts
function binds us
in a tragic fashion to the latent
function that can be
um antithetical to it in in kind of a
profound way
and so i was looking i'm watching this
and um and i and i'm saying
well yeah that that's horrible and i and
racism is a horrible thing and what
we're seeing happening here
and there's definitely i i i know this
because
you know what's happened since uh you
know 9 11 in the patriot act there's
been the militarization of the police
and and that has been a very dangerous
thing
right and i know there's there's there's
nasty tricks happening
there's voter suppression happening and
all kinds of
bad things right and people are feeling
i think legitimately
manipulated and disenfranchised and
in in powerful ways and then and this
and this is
meshing in ways that we're all finding
it hard to understand
with a history that has disadvantaged
certain groups of people and all of this
is going on and i'm saying
yes these are issues that all get
addressed so my my
if i don't mean to some freudian here
but my sort of conscious explicit
awareness is going yes yes yes but i'm
having this
negative visceral reaction to all of
this and i'm trying to go
what's going on and at first i'm oh you
know i'm making all these things and i'm
and i'm and i can feel it i'm in the
grip of something
and so i'm i'm talking about this with
my friends and i'm reflecting on it and
you know journaling about it and
everything and i'm coming to realize
oh oh and jonathan you know that i
respect your allegiance to christianity
i'm speaking about me here okay so
i uh i i said oh
this remind i'm back in my
fundamentalist church
and i'm the 10 year old again and i'm
being traumatized
by a puritanical form of protestantism i
am being told that i have an original
sin that i
not because of any act that i committed
but that is just because of how i was
born
and that there's an aspect of this that
is unforgivable
no matter what i do and everything i try
to do to overcome this
just makes it that much worse and
that i need i need to be absolutely
contrite
and guilty until some
obscure authority will finally pronounce
me
uh you know you know uh
saved or whatever and that and and then
what this what this brings with it
you know is bonfires and i mean i'm not
i'm not being hyperbolic jonathan i'm
talking about
gathering behind the church and putting
the rock and roll albums and the books
into a thing and
lighting it on fire like can you imagine
oh yeah
i've been through that too i i grew up
with that kind of stuff as well
okay and so and and uh and and so i'm
realizing
that the latent functionality of this is
so reminiscent of kind of a kind
of puritanical fundamentalist
protestantism
um and and again i was noticing the same
things you're noticing you know
the the acts of contrition the the
throwing down
of the stones and the high places like
from the old testament right where the
prophets are always doing that right the
the kneeling
and the confessions uh and and the
statement that there's nothing
i can do about it other than feel guilty
i was noticing how this is
uh was tremendously religious and
that that as i said to others that
upbringing like that upbringing
traumatized me
i mean i remember i remember going to
the minister in the church with my
mother when i
because i i read the bible regularly
daily
uh and and i came across the passage in
the new testament about the unforgivable
sin
oh and this just i fell into
i mean cartesian skepticism was nothing
compared to the well
i fell into about well how do i know
what it is
and how do and how like did i just do it
and if it's unforgivable i'm now doomed
i'm doomed
right and and that feeling of being
doomed and trapped
and and you know and i went to him and i
wanted what i wanted was a clear
uh definition of what it was and
and and i got i just got you know the
the usual you need to have faith and and
it was very unhealthy
and so i i i was realizing oh john you
better keep your mouth
closed about because even if you want to
speak about this
this is just going to come flowing
through you uh
because and it's good and you're going
to it's a because you have an incredible
bias
it's very hard for you to see this in a
positive light even though sort of
intellectually you can understand these
important things that we've already
mentioned
you know the rate the the racist history
uh
you know the the the the subversive
disenfranchisement of people
right uh uh the militarization of the
police all of these things are real
and they need to be addressed but uh but
i realized if i try to say anything
about this
my chances of speaking uh in a way that
i think is clear
we're like going to be seriously
undermined so i just sort of held back
but then i saw your videos and i thought
well maybe i maybe with jonathan's help
i can talk about this
so i i don't intend this to be a therapy
session that's not what's going on here
i want to be really i want to be really
open with you about where i'm coming
from
and i think
your video actually points out that this
tension
well let me i might be too bold it
suggested to me that this tension that
i'm finding in myself
is not exclusive to me that i i sense
than you
not to the degree i'm talking about but
also a tension between
you know what this might be sort of at a
manifest level
and then this unacknowledged latent
function of religiousness
and then you have some criticisms at
least implicit of this
you had towards the end you you warned
of danger in the in the first video
uh because the the the the religion that
does not know that it's a religion
is not oriented towards the ultimate and
sort of there's like a like a critique
coming like
via like or similar to what tilikud
meant you're it's
ultimately it's an idolatrous for all of
its bringing down of images
it's ultimately an idolatrous religion
and then i was thinking about this
when i was thinking about how uh
you know that politics is is has in many
ways taken over
uh the domain of religion i don't think
well uh
it's drenched the 20th century in blood
uh but
i noted that well there's sort of two
religions are supposed to have like you
said there's supposed to be moments of
communitas
and transformation and i'm trying to
think well what are what are the only
rituals left to politics well there seem
to be two
and it was noted how they seem to split
between the right and the left
there's the demonstration of the protest
or the rally
um and and the right likes the rally and
the left likes the the the demonstration
the protest and then i'm thinking and
both of these we have good historical
evidence
don't bring about the new man the new
person the transformation
of human beings um you know and all of
the revolutions
uh left then right the french revolution
except onward
uh show that it doesn't bring about that
although there is often
a religious goal within the french
revolution and you know they're
worshiping the goddess of reason and all
that stuff right
um it doesn't actually bring about the
promised uh transformation
uh that it is uh groping towards
um and so i i was thinking that
is it possible to talk about this
sort of um in terms
uh that are kind of meta-political about
the latent functionality of the religion
and at that level legitimately criticize
it
without thereby implying that we
think or i'm not i'll speak on my behalf
not yours without thereby
implying that i think that we shouldn't
do something about the militarization of
the police
um the subversive suppression of voting
and disenfranchisement of people and
then how that has often allied itself
uh with historical factors that are
ongoing uh of racism etc
that's what i'm proposing to you is it
possible and i'd like to try and explore
that with you
but yeah that's that's sort of the frame
i want to set up yeah i think for sure
there's a
i think there are a lot of things to
deal with
in what you said a lot of things to kind
of unpack at different levels i think
maybe we can kind of separate them in
different parts so that we don't get
completely jumbled one is
to look at the possible
reinterpretation of of your experience
i'd say or the notion
of the original sin then the idea of
adam or the fall of adam what that
what that can mean and how we can
reinterpret that in a manner which is
more useful than your traumatized youth
and i
understand because i went through all
the stuff you you
you dealt with i went through the same
and even the description of like
the the idea of blaspheming the holy
spirit and everybody wondering like did
i blast you in the holy spirit you know
all of that i understand but i think
there are ways to
to reappropriate the stories
those stories and i say reappropriate is
i also believe
one of the reasons why i went towards
orthodoxy is because they have a
different
vision of of the fall of adam um
one which i think it has a healthier
balance
so that's one and then the other is then
looking also at the way in which
these protests or kovid
and the protests together kind of
just exploded into a kind of weird
catharsis
and what that means and what it's kind
of looking towards
um and so sadly the third part which
would be like how to get out of this
it that kind of this bind that we're in
is the one which i don't know
like i really i a lot of people ask me
so what should we do and i'm looking
around
and i think i don't know what to do
except i don't know what to do socially
like i think i know what to do
personally
but i don't think i know what the
societal solution is so so maybe that
one will be harder
well but i i do want to talk about that
because i've been talking about that
with other people as well so
but i'm happy with your proposal um
but like i said i'd like to put it uh
like i said into
the way in which um what's happening
it has uh you know at the level of the
latent functions
uh there's well you said it i want to
use your words there's something
dangerous happening in this as well
and i want to explicate and draw that
out um i'm happy to hear
uh your revisions and so i don't know
what to call it let's say
revisioning rather than revision yeah of
these
of these stories um and then but if you
could put that into dialogue with
because okay let me let me instead of
making a statement let me
make ask a question it's kind of a
request
i see in you know
i see an analog to a strong analog
in this movement to that version of
original sin that i was brought up with
and let's remember that the word
protestant means those who protest
i mean right there and i was brought up
in a church where
you know protesting and constantly
declaring what was evil
and what should be burnt or you know and
and that that was like that was
daily um the kind of practice
so do you think that i'm incorrect
in saying that the version of original
sin whether or not it's the right
version
i i'm going to give you space to talk
about that but do you think that that
that you know maybe overly augustinian
version of original sin is what's at
play in
in this movement right now am i
incorrect about no i think you're
definitely right i think you're
definitely right
one of the and i think it's something
that we've seen before
in the sense that maybe an inverted
version of what we've seen before
in terms of like racialized vision of
the world in the past
which is that we've taken the notion of
original sin and we've brought it down
into biology
which is the scariest thing that can
happen because
it it actually is inevitable like it
actually does become inevitable because
it's it's related it's linked in a it
not in a really scientific way at all
but
in a mythological way it's it's still
brought into a term which is using
language of of kind of biological
identity or
categories which are material categories
and so
the idea of this racialized guilt
or you know was there in kind of 17th
century
racism like kind of neo darwinism
kind of social darwinist racism this
idea that
that certain races were inferior by
their own biology and therefore
were made to be slaves or were made to
be the lower and now
we're seeing a kind of weird reversal of
that where we're saying
to be a certain race is in itself to be
the oppressor
like to be to be white is to be
guilty of the the sin of the
revolutionary thinking like
it's kind of like it's it's not
completely original sin it's
it's like the the end of the
revolutionary trend in
in thinking right the french revolution
the marxist revolutions and now we've
come to kind of the end of it where
we're actually bringing
it into almost a biological reality
where the guilt of the oppressor is
a racial guilt and it's and that's that
so that so like you said it does
relate to original sin because it means
that as
someone who has that identity whether
it's actually legitimate
scientifically or not it doesn't matter
they're still framed in those categories
as someone who has that identity i have
no way out
like i have no way out except for two
things which your people are doing
which is to self-flagellate and
to scapegoat that is to put myself
on the to put myself on the side of find
someone guiltier than me
yes and yell at him and tell him that he
has to be canceled and he has to be
excluded from society
yes the only the only two solutions yeah
and that
i like i said i i went through periods
where the
the church i was in would be riven to
bits
by exactly that that that process
repeatedly
in cycles again and again and again and
when i sort of
when i sort of woke up to that i was
like whoa this is like
like when i started reading some
literature and i realized and i
the literature like showed me what human
beings could be other than this
that was like so but you're right in the
protestant sense like if you think of
protestant sex and you notice both the
puritanist
kind of self-flagellation of of of
complete depravity
and then the shismatic notion that
all of a sudden the group i'm in is not
pure enough they're not close enough to
the truth they're not
and and then removing myself with a
little a smaller group
and then condemning those on the outside
as being
as it's like an acceleration it's always
been there it's there in every
every structure like we can talk about
that but there's an acceleration of it
in the kind of
fragmentation of of protestantism and we
see it in
intersectionality to an extent which
becomes completely absurd where
you know at some point it's so obscure
that most like regular people don't even
know what you're talking about when
trans-exclusive this and then
trans-inclusive and we don't
most people are like i don't understand
and then it's there's smaller and
smaller identities which are
are excommunicating other identities and
you don't know what's going on
yeah so i mean that to my mind that is
uh the meaning crisis on on steroids or
methamphetamine or something that's
right
so so what and i think given
the deeply deleterious effects which
we're seeing uh you and i were talking
just before we hit the record
about you know we're we're seeing you
know uh i
you know people are like they're they're
people that we're normally sort of very
sane
like in our personal relationships are
moving more towards the fringe and
they're
filled with anxiety and they're
describing their experiences surreal
i think you know the deleterious effects
of the meeting crisis are being
exacerbated
by covid and then perhaps by uh
certain latent aspects of this but i
wanted to give you the opportunity to
uh uh to to make good on your promise uh
that there's an alternative
way there's an alternative way and i
mean
i'm interested in this both
philosophically
and personally i i typically try not to
get too personal
in these conversations but this one has
to be different for the reasons i've
already articulated
and i'm putting my trust in you about
this um so
that there's an alternative way of
conceiving of
the the myth of original sin and you
know i use that word
in not in a pejorative fashion uh but
and so what do you
what is that alternative understanding
to your mind
so the way to understand it is to
clearly differentiate between sin
and death they're related but they're
they're different
um and so in scripture it says the wages
of sin
is death right and there's an idea that
even in the in scripture it never says
that we inherit the sin of adam it says
that
that we because of adam's sin we are
we are in death like we are in the in in
we are living in a world of death and
that's really the best way to
to understand it which is that sin
causes death so you you have a purpose
you miss the mark and that's that's what
death is
and so there's a there's a brokenness it
you break the system breaks down
as you miss the mark and this is happens
at every level of reality whether it's
in your own life or
in society or in the entirety of the
world
when when something misses the mark then
there's a
a breakdown which happens now we
we inherit the breakdown
of that which is before us right we
inherit death
so we are born in families that have
missed the mark we are born
of parents that have missed the mark we
are born of
systems that have missed the mark and so
because of that we
we live in a world which has an aspect
of it which is broken
we still have the aspiration of hitting
the mark and that's that's what kind of
guides us and
makes us want to live but we have to
live with the consequences of that
of that of that miss um and the
difficulty is that
when you're in a world of death that is
when you inherit the consequence
of sin so when your parents miss the
mark and they will and we know they do
yeah you inherit that and it makes it
more difficult for you to hit the mark
because you have all the baggage which
comes and you have inherited
the the the patterns of being that will
make that worse right which will which
will increase the brokenness which will
tend to fragment
okay and so that's the manner in which
we need to understand
original sin that's what it is it's the
inheritance of
brokenness so so that
and and i hope i hope you take this as a
helpful thing
that to me reminds me of um
you know certain interpretations of the
buddhist notion of karma
that there are these patterns at work
and and we
and we inherit them um and they affect
our behavior
and they they cause suffering uh and the
way
i sort of understood this at least
psychologically and existentially is
as you said you know we we pick up from
others our parents our friends and our
culture we pick up
and that you know here's where
historical racism does matter right we
pick up patterns
um that are shaping us and moving us um
in ways
that are detrimental to our aspirations
is that a fair yeah exactly
yeah but the idea is the idea is of
course
the very desire the very aspiration
that is the very possibility we have of
conceiving the good
and of seeing the point that we're
aiming at right
of of of seeing it in our view and and
moving towards it right is is the very
how can i say this is the reminder that
we are not that we don't fit in this
broken world that we are
that we are we find dissatisfaction in
the brokenness
so that's what causes our suffering but
it's also what
what can ultimately cause our hope
because we see
we can see that we're not made like
there's something in us which
wants more than this brokenness and this
this world of death there's something in
us which is which can see that which we
can aim towards
and which is the good of course um and
so that is really the
and so what let's say what christianity
shows us and like what christ shows us
is that the manner to
reach the the manner to reach
the the aim in the brokenness
is to a certain extent embrace death
and that's really the that's the hardest
thing is to embrace
death consciously embrace the brokenness
consciously
and therefore we don't become slaves of
that brokenness
right it's to see your sins to see the
place where you miss the mark
instead of just blaming your parents
because that's what you will want to do
right
you want to blame your parents you want
to blame the system
and your right to because the system is
broken your parents are broken
everything there's an aspect of
everything that's given to you which is
broken not
fully but there is an aspect of it which
is broken and the solution is to
is to actually rather see your own death
the places in you that you're
that you're dead and recapture
the the vision right recapture the aim
so this this brings me to a central uh
question that i have about this
thank you for that i think that was very
helpful so let's shift the discussion
on to um mortality then um
and the interesting thing of course and
you're aware of this i know in the greek
world is mortality has a
and heidegger developed this a lot it
has a much more encompassing notion to
it
and then that'll help lead me to my
question to you uh you know because one
of the great sins
and i think this is the right word uh in
the greek world is hubris right
uh which is to in some sense forget
your mortality right right and to think
that you
can that like that you can be a god and
you know this is captured in great
literature you know conrad's heart of
darkness
which of course is now a contentious
work but nevertheless kurtz's big sin
is hubris right he forgets and marlow's
marlo's heroism
is he commits himself to his humanity
that he will preserve
his mortality and i've been talking uh
to my son about this because
uh you know he lives with me now
partially because of covet and uh and
you know i've been
exposing him to certain ideas and he's
going but you know but i want certainty
and i'm saying well um yeah
but you can't part of what being you
know be embracing your mortality is to
realize
that no matter how good your idea might
be uh you're ultimately
a fallible human being you're finite uh
and he was going but i don't like this
and i said
but your mortality isn't just
right and and you'll see how this
connects to what you're saying in a sec
mentality isn't the fact you know like
in tolstoy's uh ivan ilitch
ivan ellich knew he was going to die
right it's not
it's not that your mortality is that
like you said in in some fundamental way
uh you know we are finite we are broken
we are not gods
so and i'm seeing this in my discussion
with him
how do you how do you because i'm trying
to work this with him as a father
getting people to embrace their
mortality
is good uh because it prevents inflation
and prevents hubris
it prevents i i suppose it would prevent
blasphemy too from a christian
perspective
um uh and as you said it helps people
uh to not uh not to fall into the era of
by criticizing others i implicitly
remove myself from that criticism right
i see all of that how do we do that
uh without the trump without
traumatizing them
sorry sorry that was a bit of a garden
path i broke no no i
i think there i think there has to be
i'm sorry that what i'm going to say
but i think that trauma is part of the
experience like i think that
death
no right no i understand but death is
death is
is traumatic like there is a trauma in
death
um and so we need like
the the church fathers and the the
ascetics they always say
two things they say remember god and
remember death
those are the two things you need to
remember i always kind of joke around
and say
you know that's the the christian
version of of like uh
mindfulness you know it's like remember
god remember death right yeah and so
the idea is that if you if you are if
you kind of remain
in your death like you said you avoid
all the problems that you talked about
and the strange paradox in christianity
is that
by doing that you actually do become god
yes like you you actually do become
deified ultimately
if you do those two things right but but
it's a non-inflationary
exactly and that's the kind of the
paradox of the the paradox of
of of creation and the paradox of uh
of the garden of eden which is that
if adam had submitted to the will of god
and not eaten of the fruit of the tree
then god would have given him the fruit
of the tree
that's the that's the tradition right
that's what many saints have said
and not only that but that that would
have been his access to the tree of life
which would have been
perfect communion with the divine and so
it is in humility that we actually reach
the highest
it's interesting i just read this
morning when i was doing alexa davina uh
rilka's passage where he talks about uh
we throw a ball
into the infinite and then it returns to
us differently
it returns to us heavier and in it's
only in that in
in having done that that we actually get
to feel the true weight of things
um and it sounds like uh you're saying
something very analogous to that
so but what about how do we avoid the
trauma i i all i can say is
the idea is obviously to place the
trauma
ultimately to place it in christ like
the ultimate trauma right is is
communion like that's the ultimate
trauma
if you really take communion seriously
you are
engaging in a traumatic experience you
are eating the flesh and blood
of the god man like you are
you are at the foot of horror like we
you know you talk about horror a lot in
your in your
in your um in your lectures and
i one of the things i do want to bring
up to you is that that is why communion
one of the aspects
of communion is to bring you into that
horror
in a manner which will which will save
you and not destroy you
right in a manner in which you can
integrate it in that it's both
a participation in horror and a
communion of love at the same time in a
paradoxical way yeah
yeah i mean well maybe we can talk about
this at some point
i mean i i do think the other sacred
brings in simultaneously it's
the symbol on right uh the the the
horrific the doctor
the horrifying function and the homing
function um in a profound way
um and that that goes back to so i mean
there's two things i want to say uh one
is
like i'm trying to but there's there's a
notion of mortality
and isn't it in the symbolism of
carrying your cross
that's analogous to the buddhist notion
that mortality isn't just death but that
the idea that moment by moment i i i'm
dying there's
there's little deaths all the time and
that if i try to avoid
that if i try to um get some kind of
permanent hold on things i'm i'm i'm i'm
just gonna
i'm gonna cut myself on that and then
i'm going to cut other people
it it it's again is that uh is that a
is that a correct analogy to you yeah of
course yeah like if you look at if you
look at the prayer of jesus
the the basic mystical prayer of the
church it has two
it has two parts right it says has an
invocation it says lord jesus christ
son of god have mercy on me a sinner and
so it's like
there's this invocation and this
remembrance of my own brokenness
remembrance of my own incapacity
and so those two movements
simultaneously they're the ones that
will and it's and it's it's also
and because i think one of the problems
of the
of the trauma of the protestant is
to a certain extent the idea that it's
weird like the idea that
you should be pure right that you should
be
but you can't and so it's like what
then what what do you do right you just
remain in this strange broken
uh broken self but
if you rather see it as this this
necessary part of
being a human person and moving towards
the good then it that then it's not as
traumatic
because you you will then see that even
the saints
lived in you know in the most difficult
temptations that
the saints were struggling with their
passions you know and those
who reached the highest had the same
frustrations you did like no one
pretends to be
if you there isn't like the holier the
person that's holier than now and that
kind of just
if you read the lives of the saints you
see the story of
broken people who their whole life
struggle with thoughts and with
temptations
you know and are delivered by god but
it's like okay if they struggle so
for 30 years you know you read you read
crazy stories of the saints where
it's like for 40 years he struggled with
the the thought
of fornication and it's like would he
struggle with that for 40 years
he actually struggled actively with that
for 40 years
okay so i need to stop complaining
because seriously i'm there's no way
that i'm doing that
so joe holland talks about this uh in
connection with
uh plato and socrates he talks about it
in terms of
he has a book called finite
transcendence uh where he said that but
theta was always
trying to keep this tension alive uh
between the relationship to
transcendence
and um the acceptance of our finitude
of our mortality um and so
i'm wondering then if there is something
like uh a feature of wisdom
i know you have your particular
christian commitments and i'm not trying
to
trespass on those but you're also not
you're not
you're not being offended which i thank
you for when i make these connections to
other
other things you you find them i think
valuable at least in discussion
but me that there seems to be a feature
of wisdom
which is this kind of tone um
between right the aspiration
in transcendence and then the deep
acceptance
of of our humanity and our mortality and
keeping them always together
is and there's a finesse to that there's
a dynamic
shifting i can't give you a rule or a
recipe for doing that
it's an ongoing ever evolving capacity
would you would you
would you think that yeah it's a motive
it's a mode of being it's
a way of being which is what will kind
of hold those two things together and i
think your image of wisdom
is particularly good in the sense that
wisdom at least in scripture at least in
the in the bible the way that wisdom is
described seems to really be
the capacity for those for let's say the
the principles or the ideals to be
united with the particular like that
seems to be
you know it's like the wisdom always
comes as like advice
on how to you know how to find a good
woman or how to
how to live your life how to deal with
money like that's how wisdom comes but
what it's it's patterning something
which is yeah which is above you know
yeah aristotle has that with sophia and
promises being brought together right
sophia is your grasping of these
universal and profound principles
and then from esis is how do you make
them contextually relevant
in a contextually sensitive manner so
this now brings me back around then
um it sounds like this this deeper
reflection
on well let's use the word sin for now
there's deeper reflection on sin uh you
know
affords us what might be missing in what
we're seeing
in the demonstrations that that
and this this is part of my concern um
that you talk about the the you know uh
inclusion as the sole
value um i talked about something
similar uh
in that that justice is the sole virtue
um and a very truncated sense of justice
uh the greek sense of justice was
always simultaneously external with
others and internal with oneself that's
really clear
and what we have is a completely we get
none we get a reduction
of all the virtues to justice and then
just the the social
aspect of justice hence the name social
justice
yeah we're not sure exactly what what
that justice entails
in terms of its particular like how it's
going to manifest well
that goes to the point i want to make
because i i
i have a concern that we are losing the
other virtues
i mean the greeks have at least the
cardinal four and then the christians
add that the next
the sacred three and so we at least had
set we at least not seven we should be
talking about
right we at least have seven we should
be talking about and we were just
talking about one
one of the ones that's considered
something like a meta virtue which is
wisdom
um you know i shared the uh what i think
one interpretation of socrates
that socrates saw that each virtue was a
way of being wise in a particular
situation
the virtues aren't separate things of
course particular ways of enacting
and so to me if that argument is good
and i think it's a good argument
talking about justice without having a
concern for wisdom
seems to me to be like really really
almost oxymoronic
um it seems to be um self-contradictory
self-undermining
and that's a very dangerous kind of
thing to be for human beings to be
embracing
embracing committing yourself deeply to
something that
is self-undermining in its foundations
um
is a very problematic thing to do what
do you think about that as a program no
i totally agree
and that's why it's one of the reasons
because
the idea of the idea of justice
seems to have something to do with
equality
although it's ill-defined as well like
what exactly do we mean by
equality and what because obviously
quality is a strange term because
you need a re you need a a category to
declare equality because you can't have
equality in everything because then
everything would just be the same like
it
so so the equality is a complicated term
and so it seems like you know it's like
the
what is it the the intersectional it's
like the diversity equity inclusion
right
that's the those are the three kind of
values that kind of mesh together in
this idea of justice
um and so the difficulty
is of course that the rev like the
revolutionary aspect of it is what you
you also talk about in the sense of it
undermining itself
it ends up eating itself and it ends up
eating itself by its very mechanism
which is that
i hate to say it this way but it's it's
inevitable to come to the fact that
there is no such thing as
equality right in terms of action total
right because it what does it mean like
everybody's smarter stupider than others
some are taller some are shorter you
know and and and it
it's individually true and it's true in
different categories and different
cities and
it's like there's difference you know
you can't have equality and so this like
weird desire for equality
ends up being ends up being a kind of
power play it seems
not not really a desire for equality but
a desire for power
so so i wonder if there's something
going on here kind of displacement
because um
and and this this is going to be really
we have to move very carefully here
um so i think what people
want to do sorry the sun's pompous but
it's hard to talk it seems it seems
plausible to me to propose
that what people want to do is reduce
the suffering of pain and distress and
then they
and then they they
have cl they're making a claim that
most suffering is just distress or maybe
all
right is caused by inequality
and of course there is truth to that
yeah
you know what when resources are not
being distributed
as fairly as they can and fairness is
not the same thing as equality this is
part of the problem
right because justice is also supposed
to be about fairness not just about
equality
um and so when
we we do cause we cause unnecessary
suffering
so so let me try and give you a bit of a
slight riff on this i see
um the the left
as really sensitive to the fact
that human beings are i'll use a greek
term here but you'll you'll find a
christian
uh analog i'm sure the human beings are
really subject to fate
that there is just shitty things that
happen to human beings because they're
finite and they're limited
and the world is an overwhelming machine
and there's historical forces and
material forces
you know you might even say powers and
principalities at work right
and people are just subject right and
that we we have to do
and that people therefore deserve our
aid
even if they haven't earned it because
if we don't do that we are ign and this
is like the aspect of sin again
we're ignoring the fact that we are
finite and we are subject to forces
beyond our control
the left gets that and i think the right
tends to forget that and that's why the
right often comes off
as cruel but what the what but right but
what the left forgets
is what the right is no matter how you
know how
hazardly they do it and stupidly they do
it is the right choice to remind
people that even though we are subject
to fate and people
should be aided beyond what they deserve
or have earned
right human beings are nevertheless also
responsible
they need to cultivate virtue because
every human being is beset by
self-deception and the only person that
can get out of self-deception
it i i can't get you out of your own
self-deception i can give you guides
but you have to go through it like you
have to go through it
i can't do that for you right it so
if it to put it in a slogan you know the
left remembers fate and forgets virtue
and the right remembers virtue and
forgets fate
and and so so
what i'm trying to get at is how
how how could we change this discussion
about justice so that we could put it
back
into what it was supposed to be paired
with which was software some
right we pursue the external justice of
trying to reduce the suffering
of others that are caused by history and
fate
has to always be counterbalanced by
sophism
the cultivation of the inner justice of
virtue
and that those for the greeks it was it
was
it was axiomatic that you had to talk
about those two things together
somehow we have gotten to the point
where we only talk about one side of
this
and i find that also a very lopsided
thing sorry that was a long thing to say
but i you know you're a deep thinker i
want to give you a lot to wrestle with
yeah well i it seems like the way that
at least when i look at the way that
things happen in in the bible
and kind of the way the emphasis that
christianity has put on it is
obviously it christianity is obviously
very very
preoccupied with the poor preoccupied
with the poor in the
broadest way you can interpret that and
those that have less
and those that have little right uh
whether it's you know whether it's the
poor in terms of their own
let's say spiritual poor or it's poor
even physically in terms of their
material
poor or it's the sick or it's those that
have no recourse like the widow and the
orphan
this is something that christianity is
extremely uh
concerned about but the way that
christianity seems to have
concerned itself about it mostly is to
ask those who have to give
right to put responsibility on those who
have to care for those
who need to be cared for sure rather
than tell those who are
lacking to go get theirs right
yeah to like to take it from those who
have it
and that's really the difference between
the revolutionary mindset
and the christian mindset and some
people might say well why
why can't it happen like why can't those
that have less just
take right take take it back and the
reason
is because the reason is very practical
reason it's because it's a
self-defeating
pattern yes the pattern which will which
will destroy itself because
there's always someone who has less than
you and there's always someone who will
be there to take from you
even though you think you are the ones
who you're the one who has lassen so you
take from that one above you but then
there's always someone below you who has
less than you and will take from you and
as soon as you take from that one above
you
the power especially then you become the
the
you become the one who is now in the
you know who's it who's going to be
shocked like the story of robespierre is
obviously the
most classic example of that happening
um and so that seems to be the way that
christianity deals with it
and there are consequences if you don't
um and the consequences need to be kind
of put in the right
position the way i kind of say it is
i don't excuse the peasants for killing
the king
right but i still think it's partly the
king's fault
right it's still it's still because the
king didn't care for the peasants that
the peasants ended up killing him and
i'm not
justifying the peasant's actions but i
am saying that
if you don't care for the poor at some
point
it's going to happen like the the the
people will come and take
theirs if you don't care for them but i
it's not morally justified that they do
i don't know if that makes sense no it
does i get what you're saying
but what i was what i was trying to well
maybe this way of bringing it back
yeah look like i'm trying to get to this
notion that
isn't just about equality or even equity
i'm trying like
yeah you know you're right jesus does
jesus both you see jesus and the buddha
both
and what's interesting is they both do
this they both
criticize equally something like cruelty
and something like hypocrisy right and
and so
what i'm saying is the the what we're
trying to bring in here as we're trying
to encompass
the the nature of human beings is that
the notion of
social justice especially if it becomes
just the pursuit of equality
does not have the machinery to deal with
it
jesus and the buddha are neither left
nor right like it doesn't make sense to
talk
right yeah exactly but you're not making
sense at all
exactly right and so the the point is
in in a very profound way they're kind
it's not that they're non-political
but they're if you'll allow me they're
meta-political oh yeah
right they're trying to get at what what
are the values
or the virtues people should be aspiring
to that are the most
responsible and i mean both senses of
the word responsible
to human nature right that's what i see
them doing and that's what i'm not
seeing in this movement i'm not seeing
the wisdom of you know like we said i'm
trying to balance these things together
of getting a deep understanding of human
nature
i'm i'm hearing a very very superficial
theory about human nature and human
history
and human culture and and
and i don't think that the version of
justice
justice is what really concerns me is
this version of justice it sounds so
easy
and and that means that to me means it's
got to be wrong because
i mean what i get from all the great
philosophers is justice real justice
i mean john rawls writes this huge book
right
like real justice is hard it's really
hard because human beings
are so incredibly complex and they have
as we've been talking about here
these you know these opposing forces and
poles
at work in them
that was a point i was trying to make
sorry you're totally right uh and i
think that
like if you look at this if you look at
how christ deals with it it's
interesting because
you know we talked about responsibility
and you can see that in
you can see the way that christ talks
about like he talks to the pharisees and
he says you're a bunch of hypocrites
and he he he talks to woe to the rich if
you don't care for the poor
and woe to you know uh and blessed are
those who are poor for they will receive
and all of this
like there's all this and is but he also
has several parables where he talks
about
the poor who don't care for what they
have
and the consequences of that like he
also has that he also
has the parable of the talents where he
talks about the servant who receives
something and doesn't make it fruitful
and therefore
has to face the consequences of not
making fruitful that which he has and so
christ
talks ab talks at all levels at the same
time you know i always say
like you said he's metapolitical he's
he's a judge and a victim
he's the king and the servant he's all
these things at the same time
uh in a very paradoxical way and so he
kind of transcends politics and it's
interesting to watch the politician
the pop the politically minded because
they see in christ
a kind of weird mirror of themselves so
the people on the left
see christ as a kind of revolutionary
yeah
bigger and the people on the right see
christ as a get your act together
type figure well you know what
neither of those really yeah i think
that was very well said jonathan
so there's what to do with this what to
do with this
this weird i the way that i think the
way to understand it and
you know you talked a little bit in our
before our conversation started about
the inevitability of religio and i think
that's really
the way that's exactly where i wanted to
go yeah this whole discussion
seems to be pointing right it's making a
very
i think plausible argument about the
inevitability
of religion the unavoidability of
religio in human endeavor
and you made uh in human existence and
you made this point
and i wanted to give you the opportunity
to expand on it you made a point of
criticizing the the new atheists
um you know uh in in how they were sort
of saying if we could just get rid of
religion
uh you know and what they did is you
know
they identified religion with a you know
belief in the supernatural
etc etc and if we just got rid of those
false beliefs
uh then that would be it and then your
point is well the people that are in
these marches
they're not advocating anything
necessarily supernatural something
perhaps transcendent
but not supernatural etc they're not
doing all but nevertheless
look at the religious behavior look at
how comprehensive and powerful it
is and look at how much it's a response
to the way the covid crisis
accelerated the meaning crisis you you
and so you and you you made that and it
was sort of a very brief thing it was
about
two or three minutes in the video but i
wanted to give you and i think this is a
good context you and i in discussion
i wanted to give you the opportunity to
expand on that yeah
well my criticism of the new atheists
you know and i i would use stephen
pinker as the
as the main example just because of the
kinds of books he's written and the kind
of statements he's made about
enlightenment and this kind of progress
and everything um
is that and i think that what you're
doing is
is a much better like the kagsai
approach and the cognitive science
approach is a much better
approach to this because there is there
is
an understanding of what a human being
is in a in a deeper way
yeah and and there's an understanding of
the reasons why we have certain patterns
and the reason why
certain things exist within us and one
of what the new atheists
seem to want to do is to see the
advantage of
reason and then want to kind of box the
human being in reason
and see everything which is outside of
reason as
the thing to get rid of as the bad thing
to get rid of there's our original sin
is everything that's outside of
reason needs to be eliminated but the
problem is that you can't eliminate it
you know and and there's a kind of weird
utopian vision
and the example i always use is the
example of sleep
you could say and reason and and uh
and awaken this you know and the idea of
kind of this more this other aspect of
us in sleep it's a good way to
understand it it's as if i told you
you could be way more productive if you
didn't sleep
like you just have to not sleep and then
you could be awake all the time and
wouldn't that be amazing like
then you would imagine how much progress
you would make like imagine how far you
would go if you would just stay awake
all the time but the reality is that you
can't
that's not just not part of being a
human being it's all these other
patterns
that we have are there and so and
they're extremely important and if you
try to get rid of them
what they do is they kind of they go
down for a little while
and then they come back like a monster
and then we'll swallow you
and that's what we're those are the
kinds of things we saw in the
in the french revolution in the russian
revolution all the
the kind of end of atheist cycle where
all of a sudden
the patterns come back like a big
monster to devour you and now we're
seeing
very similar things as well we're seeing
a secular
religious uh manifestation and it's akin
to the one we saw in the french
revolution and it's akin to the one we
saw in the russian revolution
and so and and and i always want to say
it's like
the the people who kind of made fun of
jordan peterson talking about this
it's like it's happening right now it's
happening right now
look at what's going on and you can just
poo poo it
you can toss it to the side but it's the
same pattern happening again and
the reason for the pattern is the same
like
the denial of
sorry i get excited then i just throw
myself
me too me too the the denial of certain
aspects of the human person
is going to come back yeah and so the
idea is what do you do like how do you
deal with it and to me
that's why i think that that's why i
think that
have a conscious having a conscious
religious
aspect to you that's why ritual
conscious ritual
is is important because
ritual will be there you can't avoid it
now the question is whether or not
it's part of you integrated or whether
or not you're a slave to
ritualized behavior and kind of
scapegoat and
identity forming behavior that that is
that is just part of
existence i think that was very
beautifully
said yeah they i i agree i think uh on
the first point you made it with the you
know the cog sigh and all the stuff on
relevance realization and those aspects
that are pre-rational and how how
primordial they are
and the importance of ritual so
for those of you i mean you're watching
this video you know this work
and so there's arguments there and thank
you jonathan for gesturing to them
and then as you as you were building on
that i thought of this scene and
you'll probably be able to riff on this
because it's from mythologies from
a science fiction classic uh you know
journey to the center of the earth
and um especially in the movie version
count saknason who's the villain
um they think you'll see how this
connects in just a sec
they come to him and they say well
don't you sleep and he said i never
sleep i hate those little slices of
death
and he represents exactly no and just
right
so the journey to the center of the
earth which of course has all kinds of
mythic you know uh meanings attached to
that right
but and but he's the villain and notice
how he brings together like your analogy
and how it connects back to
uh on unwillingness to accept his his
humanness his mortality
there's the hubris in here and his and
that cycles us back again to this
refusal to accept our humanity
to ultimately it's again the same kind
of
it's a it's it's a puritanical kind of
refusal to accept
our humanity um in a profound
hubristic way and that and
and that i think is what when i've
talked to people
um you know who have sort of come out of
the new atheist
movement um one of the things that
they'll
often say that started putting them off
was they got a sense of arrogance uh
attached to these people
um and you know and i'm not talking
about
and part of it is no doubt personality
there's narcissism and
stuff that but i think they might also
have been putting out their finger on
this
this sense that right
there are aspects of our humanity that
are not being given due and this is what
i mean again about justice
suffers and justice plato had this sense
that you had to give
all of the parts of the human their due
they had to be given their due regard
their due role their due place
the attempt to eradicate um
it was a deep mistake right and
right and so this this the the socrates
and the
inner justices we have to give due
regard and do place and do role
for all aspects of our humanity
if you look at if you look at the very
first
commandment or the very first place in
scripture where it talks about
something which is holy uh is
in the the description of creation and
so you have six days
then you have the seventh day which is
the day of rest and it's the day which
is set aside for god
right it's the holy day and and right
there in genesis it says that's why we
we follow the sabbath now that there's a
mystery in that which is very profound
and the mystery is that it's exactly the
mystery that the new atheists are
impo incapable of seeing which is that
the way that the world is made in the
way that consciousness is made and the
way that reason is made
is because it's a patterning system
it can never encompass everything right
it it can be coherent but it cannot be
complete
and you need to leave a bit out
for completeness to manifest itself like
in it's in its mystery so you need to
leave a bit
on the edge that is not closed that
isn't
tied up that isn't accounted for there
has to be some aspects which are not
accounted for
if you try to account for everything
that's
the you know that's the that's the the
most
dangerous thing right it's the yeah and
if you also try to see that which is
accounted for as totality
which is the sin of satan which is the
sin of pride which is the sin of adam
that's the hubris and then then you fall
because that aspect which you which
you're which you which is
supposed to be unaccounted for which
you're trying to ignore
is still there right and and the the
fascinating aspect of that
margin or the the let's say the the
seventh day
is that there are it has two parts to it
it has a part which is the
the unfathomable of creation right the
the the completeness of creation
but it also points to the infinite
there's a secrecy in it which also
points to the infinite which is why it's
both the day of rest
but also the day set aside for god at
the same time
so it's both death and the source of
life at the same time
that's very interesting your invocation
of godel i mean i take god's theorem
that you can't have it both complete
and consistent to be an example of what
i meant earlier by mortality
that's the mortality in the heart of any
epistemological project
or you know heisenberg's uncertainty
that's the mortality in the
in the heart of any uh empirical
observation or investigation
and more and more of these right
and the the the history and philosophy
of the last two centuries have been in
philosophy and science at least the more
philosophical aspects of science have
been
in the discovery of this i'd like your
invocation of it
because it brings me back around and you
know and you i you you may
i don't if you're doing it deliberately
a lot but you're invoking
i heard lebanon when you were comparing
totality to infinity because he has a
book around that
right and how infinity is not the same
thing as totality because totality
is the pretense that you have both
consistency and completeness
that's my way of understanding it and
and therefore like
if you take the goldie uh golden's
argument seriously and you should
right that is always a dangerous
pretense
and that the problem with any any system
that
claims to be complete and consistent
is that it is actually a deep form of
self-deception
oh yeah that's for sure so
i mean and this is what you know this
was this is the great for all of the
criticisms i have of them
this is the great thing that claims
comes out of the whole pragmatism
movement
of james and pierce and dewey and more
recent people
uh you know like quine and davidson and
they've had a deep influence on me i
haven't had a chance to talk about them
very much
i will in another series but the point
i'm trying to get to here is
like there's a there's a shadow side of
totalitarianism
there's a negative version of it which
is strategies of eradication
because eradication is an attempt to be
completely consistent and complete
so there's an argument and i'm not
advocating for all of his ideas but i
just want to give due credit
uh uh coleman hughes makes this argument
about look
we all agree that murder is a deeply
immoral act and i'm not playing around
with terms well sometimes you kill but
when we say
killing that's not immoral we don't call
it murder murder is the name for the
killing we regard as immoral so let's
not play that game
so regard murder as immoral but we don't
pursue
an eradication strategy in our society
because
if we were to eradicate try to eradicate
murder
we would so we would so subject
ourselves
to a radically dehumanizing
totalitarian state that and that's why
no no that's why no culture anyway
does it right every culture has
prohibitions against murder
there's variations on it of course but
you don't see them saying and what we're
going to do is we're going to set things
up so that murder is impossible
you know philip that's a philip k deck
kind of something it's a scary thing
no and you're right about the the
strategies of eradication
these these these are extremely
frightening
because they do they they tend towards
exactly what you're talking about
and and i'm afraid that i see the same
you know and i'm afraid that i'm seeing
that right now with covid i'm seeing
exactly
a falling into a strategy of eradication
where we think that we cannot continue
to live
until this virus ceases to
exist yes this is not how the
this is not how it works this is a
dangerous because the methods you will
use
to eradicate the virus the totalitarian
methods you will use will be
extremely harmful they will be very very
harmful to
to to our our health to our community
all of these things
and it's like the thing the difficulty
that you understand
the desire to eradicate because it's a
bad thing
right this virus is a bad thing you want
it to go away
but once you enter into that strategy of
eradication especially with
techno states where you you are develop
the power to push that
capacity of eradication to its you know
to to limit that or
not seen before yeah it's a very very
frightening situation
a clear example of that is the proposal
that we
we start tracking everybody's movement
every movement
yeah i i see people do you really want
the state to have that power
do you really want the state to have
that power do you really want the
corporations to have that power
they already have that power to some
degree and they use it to manipulate
you look i i c and i can't believe it i
saw a bbc article just a few days ago
and it was just like a regular article
where they're talking about what the
future of travel will look like
and in their description of the future
of travel they talked about
they talked about vaccines with
identification
in the vaccine that they can scan your
body
so that so that you and this was a bbc
article it wasn't a conspiracy article
it wasn't like someone it was like this
is what travel is going to look like
they'll scan your body to know whether
or not you have
the vaccine and they'll let you
participate in social
things depending on whether or not they
can
track you it's like my good
have don't you watch science fiction
movies i don't know am i the only one
who watches science fiction movies
well i watch them too so i mean
and we have to be careful here so covet
is
very bad oh yeah no no no i i i want to
make an analogy here covet is very bad
and you should try as much as we can
ameliorate it but with wisdom
toggling against against overempowering
the state
and taking a dehumanized view or a
simplistic view of human nature in in
order to achieve it so we don't push for
eradication we prove
we push for amelioration that doesn't
cost us too much our humanity
isn't that the same attitude we should
take for how to deal with the very
real evil of racism that we should try
which and we should continue to try to
ameliorate it
but we shouldn't you know i talk a lot
about how you frame the problem
is way more important than the method
about act you know
about actually solving it should we be
adopting a mindset that is a
totalitarian kind of eradication
about something like racism it strikes
me that that but that argument by
analogy
means there is a a sense in which we
can go too far on this and that doesn't
i hope
that doesn't make me a racist and what
i've seen is like
i saw the interview with don lemon and i
forget the name of the actor and he was
trying to say
he's a black guy and he's right he's
trying to say i'm just saying that
that you know some of the leaders of the
movement are going
too far too extreme that's all he was
proposing and he was
he was treated with smugness and and
and dismissed and and then this horrible
argument by lemon
you know well people accuse martin
luther king of being too extreme as if
well are you saying that because
sometimes people have misused that word
that every time they use it they're
misusing it that's a really
stupid argument can we have a better
argument please
and it's like if we can't even bring up
the question
that the that we might be framing the
attempt to achieve a goal
a lot of of all that i fully support
then i think we're
we're in a very very bad place i think
we're getting into a very bad place
yeah and you're right because one of the
things covert did
was awaken in us this
this this pattern of infection
right yes yeah and it awakened us the
pattern of infection and the
desire to exclude and eradicate yeah
and now it's being politicized like not
not the kovid like
it's it's weird because you can see that
there's there's no
like there's no narrative connection
between coped and def
and floyd but there is a pattern
connection yeah and you can see that in
the that it's awakened the pattern and
now
it's playing out in the political sphere
well i mean isn't that a case
again i'm talking at the latent level
not the manifest label
but that seems like a case you know it's
like a clear
case of what a psychodynamic person
would call displacement right that
yeah that you're you're being it's like
you said kobe puts you like you're
suddenly in the old testament and i
don't mean that pejoratively right
but you know you have this ubiquitous
threatening things out there in the
world
and you have to adopt this very you know
very you know
insular purity code and then you don't
know when it's going to strike you
and and then right and they might be
infected
and and you know and and then
but now what we can do is we can't we
couldn't do anything about the covid
but i think what your suggestions but i
can do something about this over here
something about yeah and the danger
about the danger of the racist thing
is the the limit of it because the limit
is the problem with racism is that it's
this invisible thing in the sense that
it ends up being thoughts and feelings
in people
yes and the idea that you can reprogram
someone and that you can
move towards the eradication of thoughts
and feelings i mean
we know where that leads like we know
where that goes and
because it can't happen then like we
said like i said before
but it's going to end up looking like
it's scapegoating where we're going to
choose some
we're gonna find examples that we can
drag out in public
and you know and uh have struggle
session watch struggle sessions and
have them be humiliated in public so
that we can deal with the problem of
eradicating something which is which is
unconscious bias like it's unconscious
so you can how can you
eradicate it well i think
trying to eradicate that is
i mean given what we've argued isn't
that the same it's ultimately committing
you at some level to eradicating
the machinery of humanity that's right
right uh
and so
let's say that this is i've been more
and more attracted to renisjus because
of everything that's happened and i've
been
seeing that his analysis of the
situation is
is really one of the wisest in terms of
the way that he interpret what's
happening and intersectionality i mean
he passed away
i think around 2010 or maybe a bit later
um you know he talked about into i saw a
quote of his in 2007 where he talked
about
the machine of antichrist which is
ramping up and he saw
exactly what we're seeing he said it'll
be infinite victimhood
looking for infinite scapegoat and so
it's like this
perpetual wheel of victimhood which is
looking perpetually
for more and more scapegoats like almost
like a self-devouring
machine and so we're seeing it that the
solution
is like i hate to i know you dislike
when i
push it too far but the solution is the
the image of
the scapegoat being the murderer and
this and the
victim at the same time like identifying
with christ
and identifying with those that killed
him identifying with
the capacity to exclude and the reality
of also
being excluded to a certain extent like
those two things
together if you can kind of you can
integrate them properly and not in a
weird disorderly manner
can help you have compassion for those
who are excluded
but can help you also understand that
you are one of those who do that all the
time
yes you're always doing it but this this
is what i meant
i i i i think there's power in the
argument i've only read the one book and
i'm not completely
that's the one i saw satan fall like
like yeah uh but the idea that you can
explode if you'll allow me to use some
of my terms
you can explode the cultural cognitive
grammar of scapegoating
and that the christian mythos does that
i i thought that was one of the most
powerful arguments
uh and it's a new argument as far as i
know
one of the most powerful apologetic
arguments for christianity that i had
heard
in quite some time so i i think that is
a good point that you brought up
um but but it does i think it's
it's situated within this larger task
again which we
keep coming back to of trying to get to
a place where we can simultaneously
accept faith and virtue
because one of the ways in which you can
right
one of the ways in which you can address
people's
thoughts and feelings is by inspiring
them to aspire to virtue
rather than trying to eradicate you can
uh try to inspire the aspiration to
virtue
and and this has been uh to my mind
you know a very very successful strategy
um
well i've been talking a lot recently
and a cure that dawn did the meaning
wave about it
about stealing the culture and i
actually use uh christianity as a
primary example of that that
christianity doesn't try and over
throw uh the political structure what it
does is
it steals the culture it creates an
entirely different culture
from the bottom up and then because the
problem
to my mind what the french revolution
shows is you can radically transform the
state
but if you don't transform the
underlying cultural cognitive grammar
and normativity
nothing is fundamentally going to change
yeah you just changed the you just
changed the ones who were holding the
reins and you used
to circulate you circulate the elites
exactly right
and so whereas what christianity does is
and and
is is it it builds a new civilization
buddhism does the same thing right it
builds a new civilization
islam does the same thing it builds a
new civilization
and and so that brings us and we don't
have much time
uh i suppose but so that brings me
towards the third point which
you said you you know you sort of
despair of knowing what to do
um and i'm wondering if you
i realized i might be daring the
prehostess thing of proposing
uh some sort of a christian thing to a
christian which is a ridiculous thing
um but i gave you all of those examples
uh and to my mind of the idea of
well isn't the response to do as much as
we can
to engage in building the next culture
and that sounds preposterous
but a commitment to that kind of thing
seems to me to be the
most responsible response to the depth
of the situation
we are in right now yeah no i think so i
think
i mean i would say on a personal level
it's
it's just it i mean love god love your
neighbor is is a pretty
pretty good thing to live by in in the
immediate reality
and not abstract categories to deal you
know to love the people that you
that you encounter with to see in them
the face of god is something that
will transform at least your life it's
harder in terms of
like a social responsibility for sure
myself
the way that i the way that i frame it
that's why i'm doing what i'm doing what
you said is that i'm trying to
help people see the the grammar of
culture or see the pattern and
of course one of the things i've been
emphasizing the most is the importance
of the margin
and talking about the margin in a
balanced way so that you neither have
the desire
to because both sides want to eliminate
the margin
everybody wants to eliminate it they
want to eliminate the margin
either by making it the same as the
center by integrating
all the marginal aspects and making them
equal to everything else
or by eradication or by cutting it off
and that's those are that's the real
problem with the
like it's the question we had during the
the
the first wave of violence of the 20th
century you had two sides you had one
side which wanted to create
an equal utopia and one which wanted to
create
a hierarchical utopia that cut off the
margin
that burned it off and so and we're
facing the same
it's like we didn't deal with it we're
facing the same problem now
and we're seeing the one side now we're
seeing the we're seeing the
the the side that wants everything to be
equal but
i always tell people that when the nazis
came to germany they were on the verge
of a communist revolution it's not
the the pendulum doesn't move in one
direction no the pendulum swings and
and and it's a scary thing to watch
well but this is part of the way in
which again
the the way in which this lack of the
lack of
of a dynamical nuance in thinking
so you know leo ferrara and i talk about
this idea that
you in in living systems and
right you you see opponent processing
and i've argued right and that
what an opponent processing means this
is the way you deal with trade-offs
and we've been talking about trade-offs
all the way through right you have
opponent processing
you like your parasympathetic and
sympathetic nervous system like the
sympathetic nervous system is biased
it tries to interpret everything as a
threat or an opportunity and it arouses
you
and the parasympathetic system is biased
and it tries to interpret everything as
a signal that you should relax
and calm down and they're working their
biases work in opposite direction but
they're functionally integrated together
because that's how you get the most
self-corrective system
and what we were supposed to have and
you can see this in dewey right
because we're supposed to have a point
processing but what it's
devolved into is adversarial processing
yeah
right and this is the eradication idea
the adve it says zero now it's a
zero-sum game i've given up the idea of
self-correction
i've given up the idea of commitment to
a process that you and i
even though we disagree we can we can
commit to like you
and i do in dialogue we have
disagreements but we see the potential
that we can correct each other in
valuable ways that we mutually
appreciate
right there was that commitment and that
commitment to that process has been lost
like the fact that most americans
are are more distrusting of the opposite
party
than they are a foreign threat like what
the heck does that mean
right what like what does that mean to
you like like
and so the adversarial eradicate the
other
destroy the other zero-sun game
mentality
i think has made the process
i think it's broken yeah i i think the
process is broken
and and so i don't i don't know i
i i don't see how i mean and layman
pascal and others they disagree with me
on this
i don't know how to work within that um
in a way
uh and so that's what i mean by steal
the culture that
i i don't know if working within that
machinery is a viable
strategy i think no strategy has to be
uh
you know jonathan i was at a conference
uh two weeks ago uh called the movement
summit and there's
all these communities of practice
springing up everywhere
or trying to integrate mindfulness and
movement practices and discourse
practices
um and and so many of them and you know
and these people
and they're all and they all want to
talk to each other and they want to
network
and and it felt very different
this is it felt very it was neither you
know the revolution
of the uh of the left or the law and
order of the right it was
orthogonal to that it was these peoples
trying to seriously
time and talent and money and energy
and commitment to the cultivation of
wisdom
in on a deeply alternative way of being
and to my mind that's where and
i know you think it should be given a
particular christian's plan but i
also think you're charitable enough to
include other people of good faith who
are willing to work with you
i think that's where the answer uh to
the
the more difficult problem lies i think
there is stuff actually happening
right here right now culturally
symbolically existentially
that is where the diff the difference
that is needed is starting to be
generated
ah but i i i for sure agree i think that
like a way to see it is like that this
is
horrible because it has bad implications
but like the seeds of the next world
will appear in the current one right yes
like they
they're just hard to see you know the
little sprouts are hard to see
because everything else is burning in
the forest right so it's it's difficult
to see the
the the seeds as this is kind of
breaking apart
and uh and i mean i'm curious to see how
all of this will be integrated
i do i do again like you know we
we we've talked about this before right
so we're not going to come to a
conclusion
but i do i do think that there is a need
for
a a narrative cohesion and and i
and i do think that until until
something happens
in the west it's still it's still the
christian narrative so i don't
i don't see a way out of it for at least
you know i don't see a way out of it so
but i i appreciate i do think that the
questions that people are asking
and that the desire for wisdom and the
desire
for transformation is one which
will bear fruit it won't it has to if
it's done with sincerity and done
you know in a desire for transformation
it will bear fruit
yeah and the point i'm trying to make is
thank you for saying that
um and and yeah and you know from my
part i don't
i don't ever claim to have a foreclosure
argument against christianity
i i i always say that i do not have such
a fit
um uh but what i was trying to emphasize
is
there's not only sincerity there's depth
in like what's going on here
it has the the appreciation for humanity
and complexity
uh that's what i'm seeing in in these
people in this movement
of course we're all flawed human beings
i'm not i'm i'm not painting some utopic
vision
but i'm talking about you know
a real a real possibility and
and the acknowledgement that i think it
it it's it's it's in existence i like
your metaphor
for all the ways it's fraught but i do
like your metaphor of the seeds
i do like putting the two together that
the burning of the forest actually
fertilizes the seeds in the way they
need to be
fertilized and perhaps you were alluding
to that with and your wry smile
yeah but it's not it's not a fun it's
not fun like it's not pleasurable
no there's and it means it means death
and suffering
yep and i have kids and i and i don't
want this
but i want and what needs to happen
are not always the same thing yeah um
jonathan i think maybe this would be a
good place to bring it to a close
um so um
i propose to you privately and you
already agreed so i'm going to do it
publicly
uh i think that you and i and paul
should have a
uh have a discussion like this a
dialogue as i would call it
at length for the three of us and i i'd
like to invite you and then
i've also invited paul and let's let's
try and work to make it happen
because i think it would be a very
beneficial for all of our respective
listeners
yeah that would be great i would i would
love that if we let's set it up
okay so i'll reach out to paul and uh
i'll try and make it happen so i found
um
well you could see i got passionate
which means this was definitely uh
this is definitely dear logos for me uh
i always say that the difference
between a deal logos and a monologue is
both people
find themselves deduced they find
themselves drawn to a place they
couldn't get to individually
on their own and there's a kind of
education and then that that's very
different from just sort of thinking in
your own head
and so um i always find that the case
when i get into such a dialogue with you
and i wanted to thank you for you had so
many
so many insightful uh and brilliant ways
uh uh uh by which so many insights and
brilliant things you said and
and not only what you said the manner in
which you said the imagery that you used
was itself often uh deeply helpful so
thank you very much
thank you very very much well you know i
really i always enjoy talking to you and
i
and i really appreciate the insight
you're bringing to the conversation and
i'm
looking forward to seeing where this is
going and kind of how
how this is slowly going to to to to
let's say play dance together is the
best way to maybe yeah so yeah
i agree i agree okay so thank you very
much
all right john it was good to talk to
you good talk to you all right bye-bye
bye-bye